i wanted to be as authentic as i could
the romantic speculation
is over michael b jordan and lori harvey
are a couple
a little anxious i'm excited the
relationship was made
instagram official on sunday with
michael and laurie sharing these
romantic photos
tagging each other in the loving pics
taken by leo valsey with
lori captioning her post with a heart
emoji the 33 year old actor has been
famously private about his love life
and has never gone public with a partner
before now
the source tells e.t michael and lori
have been dating for months
adding that michael has been ready for a
serious relationship for a while
and they had been friends for years
before they got together in 2020.
the pair have even met each other's
families which seemingly includes
laurie's famous dad comedian and family
feud host
steve harvey men are very simple are
they
men are very so the source says michael
and lori are really into each other
and have a lot of fun together
this couple's news follows an exciting
time for the black panther star
he's dangerous i'm dangerous michael's
creed co-star tessa thompson just
revealed michael will be directing the
upcoming third installment of the
franchise
he's sexy he's alive and lucky lori her
boyfriend is also the reigning sexiest
man alive
michael hilariously announced the new
title on jimmy kimmel live in november
i think even maybe more rewarding for
you is look
michael jordan is a tiny little sexy
person
and you're the big sexy person
i'll take that difference i'm not gonna
have too many of those over mj so i'm
gonna take that one